davos is here so i'm immersing myself in
everything i can to learn more about it
and i read this book davos man it's
about this concept that the richest
billionaires in the world sort of
transcend any nationality and they
attend davos and they make these big
decisions that impact all of the rest of
our lives throughout the year so i
reached out to the author and i'm gonna
hop on zoom and chat with him about the
impact these billionaires have on all of
us not just in the context of davos but
in the context of our lives
hey peter goodman can you hear me i can
hear you fine can you hear me i can hear
you and i can see you well we can jump
right in just to kick us off for someone
who's not familiar what is davos man
davos man
is the billionaire class especially the
part of it that goes to the world
economic forum in davos that would have
us believe that if we organize our
economies around helping them make more
money we will all win something that has
in reality happened zero times
when you think about that in the context
of davos you have these people attending
who are making promises to make things
better that you lying out in the book
they're also making worse in their
day-to-day jobs what's making that
dichotomy there's a reason why we keep
falling for what i refer to in the book
as the cosmic lie this idea that if we
just organize our societies around
delivering more wealth to the people who
already have most of it will get all of
these magical things like better jobs at
higher wages and investment and
innovation
one part of the equation always does
happen and that's the part where davos
man ends up with more money and it's not
an accident it's because davos man has
used his money
to buy the political system through
lobbyists through the forging of fresh
tax loopholes and exploiting the ones
that are already there
persuading governments not to enforce
antitrust laws and so monopoly power
grows rules that have limited the
ability of labor unions to organize
which means that workers can't get their
piece of the action what would your
advice be to listeners who might hear a
sound bite from a ceo talking about you
know net zero for example or some pledge
to make the world a better place what's
the rubric that listeners should adopt
to suss out the validity of those
promises show me the money talk is cheap
it turns out that nobody is as generous
with their actual dollars as they are
with their pledges and their press
releases davos functions as this
elaborate prophylactic against us the
people using our democratic rights to
actually have a say over the policies
that dictate how capitalism works
my takeaway is not to demonize these
guys i'm sure mark benioff's good at
running a software company just as larry
fink seems to be pretty good at managing
money and thank you jeff bezos for the
miracle of e-commerce i'm just saying we
got to get over this idea that we can
outsource all of life's problems to
these very smart very driven people and
we got to get back to having to say
ourselves in the context of our
democracies really helpful peter thank
you so much for making time to chat with
me today i really appreciate it thanks
so much for having me i'll let you know
how my davos experience goes all right
hang in there so follow us all week for
davos coverage right here on quick take
[Music]
you